De acuerdo con la llamada a la policía,
los testigos oyeron gritar a las chicas.
El hombre entró en la cocina y disparó un solo disparo en la cadera de Yusor,
inmovilizándola.
Luego se acercó a ella por detrás,
apretó el cañón del arma contra su cabeza,
y de una sola bala, le voló el cerebro.
Luego se volvió hacia Razan que gritaba por su vida,
la ejecutó de un solo disparo en la nuca matándola.
Al salir, le disparó a Deah una última vez --una bala en la boca--
sumando así un total de ocho balas:
dos alojadas en la cabeza,
dos en el pecho
y el resto en las extremidades.
Deah, Yusor y Razan fueron ejecutados
en un lugar considerado seguro: en su casa.
Este hombre los había acosado durante meses.
llamando a su puerta,
amenazándoles con su arma en un par de ocasiones.
Su muro de Facebook estaba lleno de mensajes anti-religiosas.
Yusor se sintió muy amenazada por él.
Nada más mudarse, el hombre le dijo a Yusor y a su madre que no les caía bien.
Cómo respuesta, la mamá de Yusor animó a su hija a ser amable con el vecino,
ya que al llegar a conocerlas, se daría cuenta de cómo son.
Supongo que todos nos hemos vuelto tan insensibles al odio
que no podemos ni siquiera imaginar que puede convertirse en violencia letal.
El hombre que asesinó a mi hermano
se entregó a la policía poco después de los asesinatos,
diciendo que ejecutó a tres niños después de una disputa de tráfico.
La policía emitió rápidamente una declaración pública
esa misma mañana, haciéndose eco de sus afirmaciones
y sin molestarse en cuestionarlas o investigarlas más a fondo.
Resulta que no hubo tal disputa.
No hubo discusión alguna.
Ninguna ofensa.
Pero el daño ya se hizo.
En menos de 24 horas, las palabras "disputa de tráfico"
ya se habían convertido en la noticia del día.
Me siento en la cama de mi hermano y recuerdo sus palabras,
las palabras que me regaló tan libremente y con tanto amor:
"Soy quien soy gracias a ti".
Eso es lo que me hace falta
para dejar atrás el dolor y empezar a hablar.
No puedo permitir que las muertes en mi familia sean un tema
apenas mencionado en la prensa local.
Fueron asesinados por su vecino debido a su fe,
y a un trozo de tela que llevaban en la cabeza,
porque se declararon abiertamente musulmanes.
En aquel momento sentí la misma ira
que sentirían Uds. si los roles se invirtieran,
y un árabe, un musulmán o alguien que parezca musulmán
hubiera ejecutado a 3 estadounidenses blancos estudiantes de universidad en su casa.
¿Cómo hubieran etiquetado esto?
Un ataque terrorista.
Cuando los hombres blancos cometen actos de violencia en EE.UU.,
son lobos solitarios, enfermos mentales,
o empujados por una disputa de tráfico.
Me di cuenta de que tenía que dar voz a mi familia
e hice lo único podía,
enviar un mensaje de Facebook a todos los que conozco en las redes.
Un par de horas más tarde,
entra en una casa llena de amigos y parientes,
nuestro vecino Neal,
que se sienta junto a mis padres y pregunta: "¿Qué puedo hacer?"
Neal tenía más de dos décadas de experiencia en periodismo,
pero dejó claro que no estaba allí en calidad de periodista,
sino cómo vecino que quiere ayudar.
Le pregunté qué pensaba que debíamos hacer,
dado el bombardeo de peticiones de entrevistas de los medios locales.
Se ofreció a organizar una rueda de prensa en un centro comunitario local.
Aún no tengo palabras para agradecerle.
"Solo dime cuándo, y llamaré a todos los periodistas", dijo.
Hizo por nosotros lo que nosotros no fuimos capaces
en aquel momento devastador.
Leí el comunicado de prensa,
con el uniforme médico aún puesto de la noche anterior.
Y en menos de 24 horas tras los asesinatos
Anderson Cooper me entrevista en la sede de la CNN.
Al día siguiente, los principales periódicos
--incluyendo The New York Times, Chicago Tribune--
publicaron la historia de Deah, Yusor y Razan,
dándonos la posibilidad de contar nuestra versión
y llamar la atención acerca del odio contra los musulmanes.
Hoy en día parece ser que la islamofobia
es una forma socialmente aceptable de intolerancia
y solo queda aguantar y sonreír.
Las miradas desagradables,
el miedo visible al subir a un avión,
los registros al azar en el aeropuerto que suceden un 99 % de veces.
Y eso no es todo.
Tenemos políticos que nos quitan derechos políticos y económicos.
Aquí en EE.UU., tenemos candidatos presidenciales como Donald Trump,
que casualmente pide un censo especial de los musulmanes estadounidenses,
y prohíbe a los inmigrantes y refugiados musulmanes entrar al país.
No es casualidad que los crímenes de odio aumentan a la vez que el ciclo electoral.
Hace solo un par de meses, Khalid Jabara, un cristiano libanés-estadounidense,
fue asesinado en Oklahoma por su vecino,
un hombre que le llamó "árabe sucio".
Este hombre ya había estado solo 8 meses en prisión
por intentar atropellar a la madre de Khalid con su coche.
Es improbable haber oído sobre la historia de Khalid
porque no tuvo titulares en la prensa nacional.
Lo menos que podemos hacer es llamarla por su nombre:
un crimen de odio.
Lo menos que podemos hacer es hablar de ello,
porque la violencia y el odio no ocurren en el vacío.
No mucho después de volver al trabajo,
me encargaron las visitas médicas en el hospital,
cuando una de mis pacientes ve a mi compañera
gesticulando y diciéndole: "San Bernardino",
haciendo referencia a un reciente ataque terrorista.
Aquí estoy, acababa de perder a 3 miembros de la familia debido a la islamofobia,
reconocida portavoz del programa sobre cómo lidiar con esas micro-agresiones
y, aun así, nadie dijo nada.
Estaba consternada, humillada.
Días más tarde visité a la misma paciente,
que me mira y me dice:
"Tu gente está matando gente en Los Ángeles".
Yo miro alrededor esperando.
De nuevo:
silencio.
Me doy cuenta de que una vez más, tengo que hablar en mi nombre.
Me siento en su cama y le pregunto suavemente:
"¿Alguna vez he hecho algo más que tratarle con respeto y amabilidad?
¿He hecho algo menos que cuidarla con compasión?
Baja la cabeza y se da cuenta de que lo que dijo estuvo mal,
y delante de todo mi equipo, se disculpa y dice:
"Debería haberlo sabido. Soy estadounidense de origen mexicano.
Me tratan igual que yo te traté a ti todo el tiempo".
Muchos de nosotros somos victimas de estas micro-agresiones a diario.
Es posible que lo hayan vivido
ya sea por tu raza, sexualidad o creencias religiosas.
Todos hemos sido testigos de algo malo y no hablamos.
Tal vez no contábamos con los medios para responder en aquel momento.
Tal vez ni siquiera nos dimos cuenta de nuestros prejuicios.
Todos estamos de acuerdo con que la intolerancia es inaceptable,
pero cuando la presenciamos, nos callamos porque nos hace sentirnos incómodos.
Pero enfrentarse a esa incomodidad
significa también entrar en territorio amigo.
En EE.UU. hay más de 3 millones de musulmanes.
Eso solo significa un 1 % de la población total.
Martin Luther King dijo una vez:
"Al final no recordaremos las palabras de nuestros enemigos
sino el silencio de nuestros amigos".
¿Qué hizo de mi vecino Neal un aliado tan cercano?
Un par de cosas.
Estuvo a mi lado como vecino preocupado,
que también ofreció su experiencia profesional y unos recursos
cuando hizo falta.
Otros han hecho lo mismo.
Larycia Hawkins recurrió a su plataforma
en calidad de primera profesora afro-estadounidense en Wheaton College
para pedir que se lleve el hijab cómo muestra de apoyo
a las mujeres musulmanas que diariamente se enfrentan a la discriminación.
Como resultado perdió su trabajo.
En menos de un mes trabajaba en una facultad de la Universidad de Virginia,
en pluralismo, raza, fe y cultura.
El co-fundador de Reddit, Alexis Ohanian,
demostró que no todo el apoyo activo tiene que ser tan serio.
Él apoyó la misión de una quinceañera musulmana
que quería introducir un emoticón con el hijab.
(Risas)
Es un simple gesto,
pero tiene un impacto subconsciente significativo
en la nacionalización y la humanización de los musulmanes,
incluyéndonos a la comunidad como "uno más" en lugar de ser "el otro".
El redactor jefe de la revista Women's Running
acaba de poner el primer hijab en la portada de una revista de fitness.
Estos son ejemplos muy diferentes
de personas que recurrieron a sus plataformas y recursos
en el mundo académico, tecnológico o los medios
para expresar activamente su apoyo.
¿Qué recursos y experiencia aportan Uds.?
¿Están dispuestos a salir de su zona de confort
y hablar cuando sean testigos de la intolerancia llena de odio?
¿Actuarán cómo Neal?
En esta historia salieron unos cuantos vecinos.
Uds., en sus respectivas comunidades, todos tienen un vecino musulmán,
un colega o amigo con el que su hijo juega en la escuela.
Abran un diálogo con ellos.
Háganles saber que Uds. son solidarios.
No parece mucho,
pero les prometo que significa mucho.
Nada hay que nos devuelva a Deah, Yusor y Razan.
Pero cuando unimos nuestras voces,
es cuando detenemos el odio.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)